très pour parler de cette contestation
contre la réforme des retraites nous
sommes avec gérard filoche ancien
inspecteur du travail bonsoir gérard
filoche m avec nous alors tout d'abord
comment s'arrête quelques instants sur
ce chiffre de la mobilisation c'est
toujours un petit peu pardonnez-moi mais
la blague
cent trente mille manifestants à paris
selon la cgt 15000 selon le ministère de
l'intérieur dans la même villa on parle
bien de de paris on peut se demander qui
se moque de qui dans cette affaire parce
que là le delta à la 115 mille paires ça
ne croyer la cgt parce que j'ai une
expérience de 50 ans de manifestations
quel est l'intérêt du pouvoir quand il
veut diminuer eh ben ils disent les
chiffres les plus bas
on est arrivé avec castanet avec des
absurdités totales
il arrivait à dire qu'il y avait
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
quand il y avait des dizaines ou des
centaines de milliers donc la vérité
c'est que ce qui est important c'est ta
mobilisation continue je vous signale
c'est à dire ça après presque 50 jours
de grève après il il ya des conflits
sont deux c'est une foultitude
aujourd'hui vous avez les et boire vous
avez les jeunes un étudiant et lycéen
alors le ministère communique en disant
qu' il ya 4 40 bahut lycées qui sont en
mouvement
en fait c'est 40% et maintenant ils sont
obligés de mettre des crs
les gamins pour qu'ils passent leur bac
blanc dans le temps ça quand même ça
indigne et les gens nous fait rentrer
des crs dans les écoles dans les
universités macron à banaliser ça c'est
une violence absolument quotidienne et
c'est d'ailleurs grâce à la violence qui
a si patent de manifestants que ça parce
que les gens ont eu peur c'était le cas
des gilet jaune on a quand même eu 29
ont perdu un oeil et 5 ont perdu une
main et la violence la brutalité des
arrestations le matraquage le passage à
tabac
les gardes à vue garde à vue pour des
gamins maintenant le fait dans d'autres
d'entrée dans les établissements eux
mêmes ça fait qu'on est dans une sorte
de guerre sociale cemac rookie pessah
depuis deux ans rendez vous compte
comment ils vivent mais il veut changer
ce pays à la schlague il a décidé qu'il
irait jusqu'au bout comme si c'était une
guerre civile
d'ailleurs macron s'est fait élire avec
un livre qui dit révolution en face qui
fait c'est une contre révolution
c'est à dire qu'ils essaient de
reprendre tous les acquis sociaux que
nous avons sous nos parents aux
grands-parents ont réussi à obtenir lui
il fait la boule à zéro des français
sont pour au parlement il ya le
vice-président du conseil d'état bruno
lasserre qui a appelé aujourd'hui à se
montrer je suis plus sélectifs sur les
réformes nécessitant une étude d'impact
afin de faire moins mais mieux
est ce que vous êtes d'accord je suis là
c'est vrai que quand le conseil d'état
est aussi sévère avec un gouvernement
sait qu'il a peu à la maison parce
qu'ils ont commencé par dire que le
projet était lacunaire donc avec des
trous ils ont commencé par dire qu'en
vérité il n'était pas fiable
juridiquement donc contestable au
conseil constitutionnel et ensuite quand
il découvre les aînés les ex des
exemples qui sont donnés le quotidien
qui explique qu' il avait donné des
exemples pour les femmes dans ses rangs
un certain nombre de cas ces exemples
sont révélées catastrophiques qui les
sortirait le gouvernement dire qu'ils
vont à la godille
il va y avoir plus de régime entre
guillemets spéciaux après qu'avant 1 et
ils savent à désorganiser l'ensemble du
principe des retraites pour ça que 61%
des français sont pour retrait parce que
moi je dis faut arrêter les dégâts jeudi
jusqu'où on va parce que le gouvernement
sont déterminés à poursuivre
les opposants aussi s'arrêter comment on
peut sortir de là par un référendum
comme le propose luc mélenchon mais
macron est un fanatique il faut qu'ils
entendre quand même je veux dire il
voulait une france aux start up sont une
société son statut de société post
salariale
ils voulaient casser le code du travail
ils vont supprimer toutes les
cotisations sociales faut qu'il arrête
ça passe pas donc ça fait du bien
excuse moi le vent du bordel dans son
propre parti qui n'en n'est pas un il
est 20 d'émissions les autres éclate et
caetera et des cantons et quentin
qu'elle se serait la responsabilité d'un
homme d'état c'est d'écouter d'arrêter
je fais une pause et ont redit ce que
tout parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
vraiment discuter ils ont fait des
fausses concertation il est vrai vous
asseoir à la table mais avait déjà vendu
la scala en voulait à peine de commencer
et de commencer ils protestent contre
les amendements ont fait sauf une
procédure accélérée en 15 joie le
maquereau dans le temps des infos des
batteries l'avait prévu tout un débat
même à un moment donné après les
municipales pendant trois mois et
maintenant ils raccourcissent en quinze
jours tellement ils ont peur tellement
ils ont mal tellement ils peuvent pas
répondre aux amendements successifs qui
arrivent et donc on va avoir un débat
parlementaire à la schlague par coup de
force après avoir des violences pour
faire passer un projet qui lui même est
hésitante il ya déjà encore qu'ils se
trompent le jour je discutais est une
femme elle me dit mais moi je vais quand
même avoir 1000 euros il finit mais
madame vous avez combien d'années de
travail avis 25 ans ça marchera pas vomi
l'euro parce que faut quarante trois ans
pour avoir les meilleurs au fond une
carrière complète
quelqu'un me dit mais c'est parce qu'il
ya eu des problèmes de finances dans les
retraites mais non il n'y a pas de
problème en financement patron lui même
a écrit qui avait pas de problème de
finance il s'était engagé dans sa
campagne électorale à dire qu'il ne
toucherait pas au niveau des pensions et
qu'il n'a l'on grimpe à la durée du
travail qui ne repousserait pas l'âge de
départ
il fait tout le contraire est un menteur
au sens strict par rapport à ton propre
programme et donc maintenant ils ont
fait attendait
3 milliards 7 de cadeaux aux salaires
les plus élevés c'était au dessus de 120
mille euros pour gagner 120 mio il y en
a pas beaucoup moins de 1 % 1 est en
dessous de 329 euros
ils ont dit qu'is baisser le taux de
cotisation de 28% à 2,8 pour sa 3
milliards cette pouf balance il cherche
après l'argent pour prier ils gaspillent
fonds souffre avec 3 milliards 7
donc tout ça ne tient pas debout et
quand un gouvernement aciman agir iliad
mélange de tous de fanatisme
d'incompétence de violence anti sociale
de volonté d'aller jusqu'au bout d'un
programme qui casse le progrès à la
retraite telle qu'elle est la dentelle
calais c 314 nea le sécurité sociale
c'est 504 milliard huit cent vingt
milliards qui échappe aux banques aux
fonds de pension etc donc macron qui est
au service des bandits je vous récupérer
cet argent vous leur prendre je la
remets dedans et ben ils échouent les
les français vont pas se laisser faire
les salariés c'est 30 millions de
salariés on habille un cirque pour
gagner ses droits en 1910 avec 3
millions de salariés on a commencé à
gagner des droits et c'est pas quand on
est 30 millions qui va réussir à nous
les enlever
et donc voilà on est en armement on
l'affrontement continue et il n'y a
qu'une issue c'est le retrait merci
l'ancien inspecteur du travail d'avoir
été avec nous